das ist gut dass es jetzt so gekommen
ist dass wir das jetzt plötzlich auf
clustern und dann sagen na ja aber das
ist eigentlich guter micra gar kein
richtiger mit krankheiten
wir müssen schon einen schicken mit
grant haben daran einen einer aus uganda
oder tansania ein ausnahmen und
vielleicht noch einen aus syrien und
woran sehr das ist dann sind wir richtig
gut da hörst aufgestellt und das ist nur
der befriedung von eitelkeiten
[Musik]
die erste frage von 13 fragen die
wichtigste frage für heute brauchen wir
eine migrations quote wenn er sagt ja in
so vielen bereichen wie möglich geht er
aus grünefeld wenn er sagt nein auf gar
keinen fall dann geht er aufs feld
[Musik]
wusstet ihr dass deutschland nach den
usa das größte einwanderungsland der
welt ist und jeder vierte der hier lebt
ist nicht hier geboren oder zumindest
ein elternteil nicht
das bedeutet wir sind ganz schön die
werft darüber brauchen wir nicht
diskutieren aber ist diese diversität
nach außen hin auch sichtbar in der
politik in großen unternehmen bei ihren
lieblingssendungen zum beispiel hier bei
310 fragen
fakt ist menschen die von rassismus
betroffen sind kommen an diese position
sehr viel schwieriger bei 310 fragen
wollen wir diskutieren wie sich das
verändern lässt wäre eine migrations
quote sinnvoll ja oder nein grün oder
gelb wo würdet ihr stehen beschreibt in
die kommentare
ja ich hab's noch mal ganz wichtig
bedeutet es ab jetzt wenn ihr der
gegenseite zustimmt dann geht er einen
schritt nach vorne
und wenn jemand etwas sagt was euch
blüten macht könnt ihr das auch schon
während des sprechens der anderen
personen deutlich nach indem er einen
schritt zurückgeht also ihr könnt das
gerne
organisch in eure bewegungen hier
einfließen lassen für mich ist natürlich
irgendwie das ziel euch heute so weit
wie möglich ins kompromiss hält oder
hier am besten rein zu bekommen hat ich
würde gerne direkt bei die anfangen du
bist in berlin geboren seine eltern
kommen aus der türkei und deine jugend
und kindheit war geprägt von wenig geld
viele vorurteile und trotzdem hast es
geschafft du bist jetzt unternehmerinnen
hat es als auch ohne eine quote nach
oben geschafft warum hättest du dir denn
trotzdem eine migrationsgeschichte
ich würde meinen fall als einzelfall
glücksfall bezeichnen nicht jeder hat so
viel glück wie ich ich kann das aus
meiner familie aus meinem freundeskreis
sowie auch von meinen zuschauern die mir
jeden tag schreiben dass sie eben nicht
die gleichen chancen
und fragen mich was kann ich machen ich
bin frustriert und wie kannst du mir
helfen also kann ich nicht immer nur von
meinem glück bei ausgehen sondern es
gibt genug menschen die keine stimme
haben oder keine plattform um das eben
kunst zu tun
ich bin für eine migration boote weil
ich glaube dass es brücken schaffen kann
ich denke dass unsere diverse
gesellschafts was ich war ist aber noch
nicht genug
das fallen ihm immer noch menschen aus
diesem raster du hast deinen kopftuch
damals abgelegt und daran auch in vielen
interviews darüber gesprochen um
überhaupt einen job zu bekommen
damit hast du viele deiner zuschauer in
deiner fans wie kam das überhaupt so
weit ich habe mich als gesundheits und
krankenpflegerinnen an einer berliner
krankenpflegeschule mit job beworben und
als ich meine papiere nicht
zurückbekommen habe meine bewerbung
dachte ich wirklich jahrelang absagen
programm habe dachte ich vielleicht
liegt sie am kopftuch also hab beim
fotografen
foto machen lassen ein bewerbungsfoto
ohne kopftuch hubs in der kabine runter
genommen habe mich an derselben
krankenpflegeschule beworben hatte zwei
tage später ein vorstellungsgespräch
also war für mich hier die frage ok job
ohne kopftuch oder du bist ein kopftuch
und kein job also ich habe nicht so
viele möglichkeiten das wäre also ein
moment wo dir so eine migrationskosten
hätte davon gehe ich aus wo genau sollte
denn diese quote eingeführt werden
ich denke auf jeden fall in der
ausbildung und bildung
ansonsten nicht ich finde unternehmen
sollten die freiheit behalten selber zu
entscheiden die leute so einzustellen
vor allen dingen eben nach qualifikation
ich bin selber unternehmerin was sich
natürlich vom staat attraktiv finden
würde wenn wir zum beispiel eben steuer
ersparnis zu bekommen könnten um zu
sagen hey ist ein alteingesessenes
unternehmen hier fehlen einige
strukturen um leute eben auch zu
repräsentieren aus der gesellschaft und
zu sagen okay hier ist dieses angebot
das würde dem unternehmen steuervorteile
bringen weil ich das mal reinschauen
ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne dazu
positionieren zu dem was hat gerade
gesagt hat katharina dürr cent schritt
auf sie zugegangen
das finde ich finde ich einen guten
vorschlag ich finde positiv
unterstützung immer besser als in der
negativ subvention ich glaube das ist
auch für viele unternehmen und auch für
viele menschen die vielleicht noch in
mainz haben die sich vielleicht noch
nicht über alle schon gedanken gemacht
habe ich glaube dass das ein guter
erster schritt wäre tatsächlich personen
habe ich mit der migrations quote weil
ich kein migrationshintergrund habe
keiner vorgemacht aber mit der
frauenquote als ich selber politisch
aktiv war und ich kann nur sagen es
fühlt sich nicht besonders gut an wenn
man als quotenfrau abgestempelt wird und
auch deswegen in ein amt behoben
würzburger gehoben wird
deswegen würde ich das gerne auch einen
anderen ersparen und lieber dafür sorgen
dass es auf anderem wege funktioniert so
dass aktuell dazu bis stehen geblieben
ja ich fand diese die momentan mit
seinem unternehmen durchaus auch sehr
ansprechend und auch richtig kann ich
als unternehmer sei bestätigen ich finde
nur dass es in deutschland an den
schulen sollte die quote angewendet
wären das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden
weil in deutschland hat jeder das recht
eine schule zu besuchen
und ja ich gebe ihr recht das für mich
es nicht um migrations quote geht
sondern um chancen und da geht es um
bildung und da geht es aber auch darum
dass jeder einzelne in den rocky modus
kommt und die chancen die sich in diesem
land einem jeden bieten auch nutzt
das ist so ein bisschen für mich das
problem bei der migrations quote
da habe ich oftmals das gefühl dass
trotz der richtigen analyse des problems
der ein oder andere durch das durch die
ziellinie geschoben werden sollen das
jetzt mal sehr überspitzt auszudrücken
denn das ist nicht fair allen der
gesamtgesellschaft gegenüber wenn man
eine bestimmte gruppierung aussucht und
diese dann aus der sicht vieler dann
übervorteilt die migrations quote hat
das potenzial der gesellschaft zu
spalten weil es am ende des tages immer
eine frage der gerechtigkeit ist wenn
bevorzuge ich wem benachteilige ist wer
ist migrant aus welchem land und zu wie
viel prozent
erfahrungen aus der vergangenheit die
uns gerade heute eine lehre sein sollten
dass wir die gesellschaft so nicht
zusammenführen sondern langfristig
gespalten hat kannst du das vielleicht
mit der schule noch mal erklären
ich wollte meinen job schon in der
grundschule tragen wir sind nach
neukölln mit meinen eltern eine
neuköllner schule mit dem kopftuch bin
ich hingegangen und ich wurde nicht
genommen weil sie gesagt haben mädchen
mit kopftuch nehmen wir an diese schule
nicht deswegen eben schon vielleicht ist
es auch hier ein einzelfall aber es ist
kein einzelfall kann nicht jungen also
ja auch schön keinen schulplatz bekommen
in der grundschule aufgrund meines
kopfes also habe ich diese belehrung
diskriminierung aufgrund des kopftuch
ist das etwas was wirklich
wissenschaftlich belegt ist wir haben
einen arbeitsmarkt der frauen mit
kopftuch diskriminiert und genau
deswegen glaube ich ist es total wichtig
dass man arbeitgeber verpflichtet dazu
nachzudenken dass diese aus dieses
aussortieren entlang von merkmals
dimensionen nicht in ordnung ist und
auch nicht zu vereinbaren mit unserem
grundgesetz wir haben und
religionsfreiheit
es sollte völlig okay sein dass man
muslime ist es dürfte kein nachteil sein
wir haben im moment dieses problem das
mit sehr viel selbstverständlichkeit
eben ausgrenzung und diskriminierung
stattfindet weil sie einfach auch gar
keine negativen konsequenzen zur folge
haben und eine quote würde ein dazu
zwingen anders nachzudenken
jetzt wo hatte erzählt hat dass es bei
ihr eben schon ganz früh anfangen dass
sie andere chancen hatte als ihre weißen
mitschüler innen die keine kopf kein
kopftuch getragen haben gehst du da
einen schritt auf sie zu und kann sich
in dem punkt verstehen die forderung
nach einer migrations quote kann
natürlich befüllt werden mit vielen
einzelnen geschichten ich weiß aber
nicht ob man damit der
gesamtgesellschaftlichen friedensordnung
gerechtfertigt bleibt nach wie vor hier
stehen wally mieters nicht zur gänze
überzeugt auch wenn mir das für sie
persönlich sehr leid tut also es gibt in
dieser gesellschaft diese probleme es
gibt diese ausgrenzung erfahrung ich
glaube nur nicht das migrations quote
der schlüssel ist um dieses problem zu
lösen sondern ich glaube vielmehr dass
wir andere instrumente dafür bauen
deine eltern sind auch als gastarbeiter
nach deutschland gekommen heute bist du
lehrer am gymnasium und du wurdest aber
sagen ich würde auf gar keinen fall
aufgrund einer quote eingestellt werden
wollen warum ja richtig denn ich glaube
das ist schon darauf ankommt dass man
qualifikation for rice kompetenzen
vorweist teamfähig ist zum beispiel in
den unternehmen
in die man einsteigen möchte um mit den
teams zusammenzuarbeiten und ich möchte
ehrlich gesagt nicht mit einem quoten
stick war quasi in meinem berufsleben
oder meine karriere beginnen und der
quotenerfüllung sein ich möchte
überzeugen mit dem was ich kann und was
ich bin und mit bringe ich habe einen
migrationshintergrund
und ich habe allen widrigkeiten entgegen
mich dennoch durchsetzen können das hat
meine persönlichkeit geschärft und ich
glaube dass es wichtig ist dass auch die
generation die nach uns kommen ihre
erfahrungen ihr einen freien und offenen
wettbewerb machen
ich gehöre der zweiten generation an und
seine eltern sind vor 60 jahren in
diesem jahr jährt sich das zum
sechzigsten mal für unsere familie nach
deutschland eingewandert und ich hatte
es nicht leicht
ganz klar und ich bin ganz bei dir wenn
du sagst es ist zeit dass man diesen
robot modus eröffnet und sich wirklich
auch kämpft und auch somit auch seine
persönlichkeit bildet mich hat es sehr
gestärkt und ich weiß ich dass auch
diskriminierungserfahrungen sehr
verletzend sein können
ich habe viele absagen bekommen ich habe
viele probleme bei der wohnungssuche
gehabt und dergleichen keine frage aber
dennoch bin ich kein freund der
migrations quote weil ich glaube dass
ich das zum beispiel als lehrer meinen
schülerinnen schülern gar nicht
vermitteln kann
etliche von ihnen würden die bücher
wieder zuklappen sagen gut wenn es auf
das lernen auf die fähigkeiten
kompetenzen nicht ankommt sondern nur
auf die hautfarbe meinen glauben oder
meine herkunft um meine karriere zu
beginnen oder eingestellt zu werden
dann weiß ich nicht wo mit wir ein
junger menschen noch motivieren können
und sollen wirklich etwas zu erreichen
in karachi riss der einen schritt
entgegengekommen
ich bin absolut seiner meinung dass es
ein nachteil ist wenn man aufgrund einer
quote eingestellt ist dass das unter
umständen der eindruck entsteht da steht
jemand nur weil er jetzt irgendwie eine
hautfarbe hat zum beispiel das ist eine
problematik aber die idee die dahinter
steht ist ja nicht ich nehme jemanden
der nichts kann und nur muslim ist
sondern die idee ist ich nehme jemand
der was kann und muslime ist wir haben
wahnsinnig gut qualifizierte leute die
regelmäßig absagen bekommen nur weil sie
eben dieses eine merkmal haben es ist
andersherum gedacht ich glaube auch dass
es unglaublich wichtig ist darüber zu
sprechen dass wir aus einer ungleich
situation eine gleichheit herstellen
wollen und nicht jemand von irgendwo der
nichts kann dann plötzlich einen job
kriegt der ihm nicht zusteht wenn das so
kommunizieren dann wird es auch nicht
den effekt haben nämlich dass es
akzeptiert wird
das würde mich tatsächlich auch
interessieren was ihr dazu denkt glaubt
ihr dass eine migrations quote zu mehr
stigmatisierung von menschen mit
migrationsgeschichte führen kann
schreibe es in die kommentare also ich
möchte sie gerne darauf reagieren ich
komme da gerne ein schritt darauf zu und
zwar dein argument aus einer ungleich
situation eine gleichheit zu schaffen
mehr gleichheit zu schaffen
keine frage wir haben natürlich in
unserem land eine große ungleichheit in
der gesellschaft einkommensungleichheit
vermögensungleichheit soziale
ungleichheit bildungsgerechtigkeit
nachdem wir seit jahrzehnten im grunde
schreien und immer noch nicht sich
letztendlich eingefügt hat die
ungleichheit muss aber anders bekämpft
wir haben können wir das tatsächlich nur
mit der migrant migrations oder
migranten quote erreichen
geht es denn nicht indem wir
schülerinnen schüler jugendliche
familien schon sehr früh fördern
unterstützen bildung bildung bildung
das brauchen wir in diesem land
tatsächlich darauf müssen wir setzen auf
der einen seite respekt toleranz ganz
wichtig wir dürfen nur eins nicht
vergessen weil das gerade hier so ein
bisschen mehrfach an durchgeklungen ist
ich glaube wir sollten hier nicht zu
sehr auf einen antimuslimischen
rassismus den ist sicherlich gibt
aber fokussieren und dabei aber den
rassismus den andere erfahren meine
schülerinnen schüler indischer herkunft
meine schülerinnen schüler afrikanischer
herkunft meine schülerinnen schüler die
juden sind und über viele jahre in der
schule es verstecken und das nicht sagen
dass die jüdischen glaubens sind weil
sie eben nicht von der
mehrheitsgesellschaft im übrigen sondern
von der einwanderungsgesellschaft
diskriminiert werden
also ich kann sachen jetzt jedoch gesagt
ich muss ihn rein gehen wer genau wer
genau alles durch diese migrations quote
vielleicht vorteile bekommen könnte das
können wir später noch genauer
ausdifferenzieren aber in ketsch ii ich
würde gern noch mal auf dich zu sprechen
kommen weil du gedacht hast ja warum war
er sagte ja wir müssen auf respekt wir
brauchen toleranz das sind alles
wunderbare begriffe die aber nicht mit
inhalt gefüllt werden
wir haben teilweise auch in den
bildungssektor wo du bist wir haben das
problem dass wir teilweise mit
lehrpersonal zu tun haben die selber
sich rassistisch äußern wie soll man
denn da ansetzen und sagen ihr müsst
tolerant werden dass das ist kein
lösungsansatz wir brauchen eher mehr
beschwerdestellen für schüler und
schülerinnen
wir brauchen gesetze die auch menschen
die kinder betreuen
ganz klar verbietet sie zu
diskriminieren diese freiwilligkeit die
wir haben natürlich toleranz respekt
dass es gibt unglaublich viele
wunderbare leitlinien die existieren und
dann geht man auf dem schulhof und dann
ist die realität da und das ist eine
diskrepanz mit der wir zu tun haben und
ich bin sehr der meinung das wäre schön
wenn wir alle tolerant werden aber wir
benachteiligen wie diskriminieren wir
machen sprüche
wir grenzen aus also ich bin solange
stattfindet ohne konsequenzen ohne
sanktionen wird es auch nicht aufhören
und das ist genau das was ich sage es
muss sanktioniert sein es muss nachteile
haben wenn man zum beispiel als
arbeitgeber es sich zur gewohnheit macht
alle ausländischen namen auszusortieren
was will ich denn sagen sagt er wir
brauchen mehr regelungen oder sollten
wir einfach auf freiwilligkeit setzen
katharina hat sich einen schritt nach
hinten bewegt aber hat die czech was ich
dazu sagen wollte sagen also ich absolut
die perfekte traumwelt muss ich ganz es
eigentlich wünschte ich werden dieser
welt groß geworden fakt ist ich bin zu
einer berliner hauptschule gegangen in
neukölln meine eltern konnten wir nie
mit mathematik helfen auch nicht mit
deutsch ich bin in die schule gegangen
und mein zeugnissen steht dieses gehen
da ständig abwesend ich hatte niemand zu
dem ich gehen konnte mami hier bisschen
bibi blocksberg fakt ist dass wir in
sozial schwachen bezirken hier zum
beispiel in berlin leider diese
traumwelt halt auch nicht haben ja
eigentlich freue ich mich über das was
du gerade gesagt hast denn du hast
nichts anderes gesagt dass es um bildung
geht ich finde du bist ein
hervorragendes beispiel dafür
dort ist wirklich gar keine guten
voraussetzungen aber du bist im rocky
modus gekommen und du hast dich
entschlossen etwas aus seinem leben zu
machen und heute stehst du hier
und warum reden wir eigentlich immer
über die dinge die nicht gut
funktionieren warum reden wir über die
vielleicht negativen lebenserfahrung
ich finde es wirklich toll über die
positiven lebenserfahrung zu sprechen
über dich über die beiden erfinder von
bei und die mit einer ganzen nation
impfstoff schenken über über helden aus
kultur kreativwirtschaft fußball aus
journalisten oder aber auch soziologen
die einen doktortitel haben heute hier
unter uns weilen
also wirklich dieser helden in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen um halt einfach
auch draußen ein mindset zu verändern
wir konzentrieren uns immer sehr auf
eine negative konnotation und diese
negative anklage eine konzentration
führt immer dazu dass irgendjemand
schuld sein muss und das ist dann
wahnsinnig schwierig brücken zu bauen
und deswegen bleibe ich immer noch hier
auch wenn ich die negative erfahrung
auch zum zeit selber schon erlebt habe
aber ich finde sich dagegen sträuben und
zu versuchen ein vorbild zu sein das ist
doch das was letzten endes brücken baut
wir haben schon so viele vorbilder und
hat ja ich hab schon kurz angesprochen
du bist ja auch ein vorbild für eine
zuschauerin
sollte dir folgen damit dass du hier
gerade schießt in eine geschichte
erzählt man könnte ja nach der logik
sagen du hast es geschafft ohne eine
quote würdest du denn sagen um noch mal
auf dieses stigma thema zurückzukommen
das dass du kein vorbild mehr wäre es
wenn du durch einen migrations quote an
genau diese stelle bekommt das wo du wo
du jetzt schon bist ich stimme hinzu ich
würde auch also wieder früher wollte ich
das nur heute wollte ich das überhaupt
in eine opferrolle gesteckt werden noch
mächtig dass sich irgendjemand für meine
erfahrung bin schuldig dass es das was
mich zu der person gemacht die ich heute
bin und das ist ein puzzle teil davon
wenn mir jemand meine geschichte diesem
teil wegnimmt dann fehlt was in meiner
geschichte und ich bin letztendlich
dankbar für diese erfahrung aber weil
ich stark genug war du warst stark genug
eben aus dieser situation herauszukommen
aber ich kenne ganz ganz viele junge
menschen die nicht diese stärke haben
die das extrem zurück wirkt wenn sie
eine absage bekommen also das ist auch
eine charakter stärken nicht jeder kann
rückschläge gut verkraften ich packe
jede hürde an egal welche ich habe und
die habe ich als unternehmerin jeden tag
wenn der nächste brief kommen die
nächste e mail und ich weiß nicht was
ich machen soll mit meinen arbeiten
hauptschulabschluss aber ich stelle mich
dem und mache was und ich werde immer
erfolgreich aber das ist halt meine
hollywood-geschichte sie hat leider nun
mal nicht jeder katharina kannst du das
verstehen was hat gerade gesagt hat das
ist natürlich wenn man davon ausgeht
dass nur die die stärksten sind die
dänen meinetwegen größten kampfgeist
haben es irgendwie zum beispiel hier in
diese diskussionsrunde schaffen wir
wollen wir dann der kampfgeist quote
einführen oder also ich meine ich muss
mich genauso kämpfen ich sitze auch
jeden tag da und weiß auch mal einen
brief oder eine e-mail nichts anzufangen
und bin unternehmerin also deswegen du
hast vollkommen ich gesagt wir brauchen
vorbilder dieses das vorbild was du bist
das bin ich vielleicht auch und
vielleicht sind wir es aus den gleichen
gründen nämlich gar nicht weil ohne
migrationshintergrund hast oder weil ich
privilegiert aufgewachsen bin sondern
vielleicht weil wir einfach unsere frau
stehen in diesem falle und
unternehmerinnen sind und das auch schon
riesig viel wert es in diesem lande in
form egal woher man kommt tatsächlich
ich würde gerne noch was wir reden von
individual- geschichten wir brauchen
vorbilder wie so brauche ich ein vorbild
wenn jemand grundrechte nicht
gewährleistet werden
wir reden von grundrechten die
kontinuierlich gewissen leuten
werden wir haben laut grundgesetz egal
ob du welche herkunft du hast egal ob du
mann oder frau ist egal welche religion
du hast du gleiche chancen haben aber
dann sind wir erreicht haben aber dann
ist in der hand ist so ausbildung dass
du nur aufgrund von diesem merkmal bei
gleicher qualifikation keinen zucker
zusage bekommst beziehungsweise gleich
aussortiert wird dann haben wir ein
problem in der gleichheit vor annahme
und nicht darüber dass wir in welche
vorbilder brauchen oder hat jetzt eine
aus zehn geschafft da sieht doch super
aus aber freuen wir uns jetzt nein wir
freuen uns nicht weil zehn andere den
schlüssel nicht gehabt haben darum geht
es doch niemand hier wird sagen dass wir
da nicht noch besser werden muss ist
doch überhaupt gar keine frage
es geht aber letzten endes um die
diskussion ob die migrations quote der
schlüssel schlüssel ist um dieses
problem zu lösen und gerade weil du
aufgezählt hast dem ich den
gleichheitsgrundsatz genau da verstößt
meiner aus meiner sicht die migrations
wurde ganz erheblich ich kann aber
verstehen dass man vielleicht ein
bisschen weiter denken könnte wie
amerika und wenn es darum geht sich zu
bewerben das ganze anonymisiert in
irgendeiner form durchführen müssen also
es gibt mechanismen wo ich sage warum
denken wir da nicht ein bisschen quer
und es endlich eine frage von migrant
oder nicht migrant menschen die die
techniker und sehen ihre hände oder was
auch immer für eigenschaften haben
werden im grunde genommen einem
idealbild sozusagen müssen sie weichen
und das kann nicht sein wenn unser
erster die würde des menschen ist
unantastbar da kann ich sagen lasst uns
doch mal da an einer lösung
zusammenarbeiten wunderbar ich sehe die
quote auch nicht als einzigen wichtigen
weg ich sehe die quote als einen von
vielleicht ein potpourri von zehn
verschieden und da können wir uns gerne
wo wir dran arbeiten das eigentliche
ziel nämlich diskriminierung abzubauen
was ist denn der grund warum jemand
diskriminiert wird
wir haben zuschreibung genau die
automatisch an jede person die dieses
merkmal hat übertragen wird und daran
müssen wir arbeiten aber da haben die
realität dass wir massive vorurteile
haben dass wir und dass die angewandt
werden
und die werden in einen möglichen
gesicht
am abend war das sicher scheinende aber
das problem löst du nicht top down
unbedingt sogar ein ist das ist genau
der glaube das musst du das musst du von
unten nach oben lösen und nicht auf
dauer wie soll denn ein schüler ein
lehrer verändert ich würde gern nehme
ich nicht mal mehr rein
du bist nicht von rassismus betroffen
und trotzdem stehst du hier auf der
seite für migrations quote würdest du
denn sagen dass unsere diverse
gesellschaft sichtbar ist zum beispiel
in der politik in den medien in großen
unternehmen ich würde mir vor allem sehr
oft mehr differenzierung wünschen also
zum beispiel ich musste noch nie kämpfen
ich habe hart gearbeitet und ich habe
noch nie kämpfen müssen schönen
menschenrecht ich hatte jeden zugang zu
bildung zur gesundheit etc pp und so
geht es glaube ich sehr vielen weißen
privilegierten menschen und das ist erst
mal wichtig festzuhalten dass wege gibt
es einen großen unterschied zwischen
kämpfen und zwischen der hart arbeiten
mir ist das thema sehr wichtig weil ich
in einer der diversen gesellschaft
mittlerweile leben darf durch die arbeit
von viborg war dadurch dass wir in
südafrika in mosambik in uganda haben
dadurch dass ich sehr viele menschen
kennengelernt haben die meine
perspektiven und horizonte maximal
erweitert haben und deswegen kämpfe ich
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit ihnen
und für sie desweiteren glaube ich ist
dass es nicht um entweder oder geht
sondern sowohl als auch und wir kommen
aus einem ungleichgewicht und das kann
man sich in jeder studie anschauen und
deswegen würde ich aus meiner sicht
sagen die quote war gut um zu
übersteuern natürlich ist eine
übersteuerung und natürlich kommt dann
steht man mit und deswegen muss man auch
differenzieren und genau hinschauen
die welt ist sehr komplex in der wir
leben das heißt ich muss den
eigentlichen rassismus experten
diskriminierungs in sexismus experte et
cetera sein
das ist aber meines erachtens die
aufgabe der politik der komplexe
sachverhalte zu verstehen und strukturen
zu schaffen die langfristig zum besten
aller wesen sind und eben und das in
einer komplexen welt das schaff ich
nicht als unternehmer deswegen würde ich
mir da natürlich hilfestellungen und
starke strukturen die eben zum besten
aller wesen sind und nicht nur eine
weiße privilegierte schicht die die gar
nicht mehr repräsentiert was deutschland
ist 25 prozent sind menschen aus
migrations
deswegen haben die haben teilweise
andere bedürfnisse anderer herkunft
andere kultur die ich gar nicht als als
unternehmer zum teil kennen kann geht
eher dahin stattfinden also versteht ihr
mich ja dass er diese quote bräuchte um
das überhaupt erst durchsetzen dass man
verständnis problem und zwar wenn man
für migrations quote spricht schließt
das den letten mit ein und der ukraine
mit einem gerne darauf einstellen
ich kann natürlich sagen natürlich
migrations quote wunderbaren also ich in
lettland nach einem aparten
persönlichkeit in der ukraine
unbestimmten aus holland kommt auch
jemand um die kurve dann habe ich die
quote erfüllt ist damit das problem
gelöst oder es ist nicht gut wenn ich
mich irgendwann ganz freut ich glaube
dass das problem durchaus richtig
erkannt ist und das ist dass da was
passieren muss da wird ja gar kein
mensch der in irgendeiner form ist
unstrittig
aber ich glaube dass die neue generation
heranwächst viele die da an allen
unterschiedlichen ecken und enden
schrauben da das bewusstsein in harter
arbeit werden ändern können aber
hinzugehen und das ist gut dass es jetzt
so gekommen ist dass wir das so
plötzlich auf clustern und dann sagen na
ja aber das ist eigentlich ein guter
minister gar kein richtiger mit
krankheiten
wir müssen schon einen schicken mit
grant haben da einer aus uganda tansania
aus ihren namen und vielleicht noch
einen aus syrien hat wo man sieht wo sie
das dann sind wir richtig gut da hörst
aufgestellt und das ist nur der
befriedung von eitelkeiten aber das
liegt doch erstens die axt an die
menschenwürde die wir in diesem land
sucht so groß schreiben und zweitens
glaube ich dass wir uns daran gewöhnen
müssen dass wir von oben verordnete
lösungsmodelle da so nicht werden durch
kriegen können weil immer eine andere
benachteiligte gruppe sich melden würden
wird sagen wird momentan aber ich auch
ich möchte auch neben der migrantenquote
eine quote für haben und haben wir so
viele quoten das dann irgendwann mal
gemehrt gesellschaft sich fragt dann
kriegen wir denn eigentlich unsere quote
weil sie haben das land aufgebaut und
dann hast du eine ganz spannende
diskussion ist das auch so nicht
erwartungsgemäß ich glaube du sprichst
die gesellschaften die gesellschaft ist
eben alles und da ist ein teil die
politischen strukturen die in denen wir
leben und es geht um machtverteilung und
machtstrukturen und wenn man sich alle
zahlen anschaut dann ich heiße michael
und andreas sind zwei wirklich deutsche
typische oft langweilige namen die in
allen vorständen sitzen zu 46 prozent
da ist keine er ist schon allein wenn
wir die analogie zur frauenquote haben
wo ist in den dax unternehmen die frauen
wo sind die menschen mit
migrationshintergrund in den dax
unternehmen aber in lachs unternehmen
sind aber auch keine arbeiterkinder ja
in den vorständen schau dir die studien
an die jedenfalls unterrepräsentiert so
wenig heute eine gewisse reife an den
universitäten unterrepräsentiert sind
auch dort gibt es kaum welche
am ende geht es auch da wieder um zugang
zugang zu bildung ganz genau
gerade sind wir uns ja alle glaube ich
ein mich ja und diese ungleichgewichte
muss aufgelöst werden und da ist wieder
nochmal die migrations quote nur ein
mittel um dorthin zu kommen und da
brauchen wir noch viel mehr mittel
ich glaube aber das spiel bräuchte mehr
farben und die diversität und die
problematiken und die herausforderungen
denen wir sind darzustellen da ist eben
grün und gelb vielleicht zu wenig farben
wie genauso schwarz und weiß zu wenig
sind und wir brauchen da viel mehr
spielraum und auch viel mehr
spielerischen umgang damit damit eben es
egal ist ob sie die italiener uganda
whatever
es geht darum dass eben wie eine diverse
gesellschaft haben die dann auch diverse
lösungsansätze für eben die
herausforderung in denen wir stehen so
gehen wir über indie kompromiss konnte
ich schlage euch hat erstmal ein
kompromiss vor
und dann seid ihr dran mit den
kompromissen erste frage von 13 fragen
sind wir uns einig dass unsere diverse
gesellschaft in wichtigen bereichen wie
unternehmen politik oder auch medien
also internet radio und tv nicht genug
sichtbar ist wenn er sagt ja dann könnte
er jetzt einen schritt auf mich zugehen
[Musik]
wackelt ein bisschen bisschen so ein
halbes jahr
ok jetzt gebe ich euch zeit dass ihr die
köpfe zusammen stecken könnt und selber
überlegen könnt was wäre von eurer seite
aus einen kompromissvorschlag für die
andere seite
mit effekten welt nochmal genauer
geguckt aber es gibt wirklich keine
datenlage zu und keiner tut was geht dir
hier geradezu schaut was wäre denn euer
kompromissvorschlag wenn ihr euch jetzt
gerade auf einer seite stellen könnte
schreibt man die kommentare
das erste mal akzeptieren ok check in am
rassismus problem
was ist euer kompromissvorschlag an die
andere seite also wir werden auf jeden
fall gegen eine starre quote würden aber
wir brauchen mehr als in den unternehmen
deswegen werden wir dafür so wie es den
datenschutzbeauftragten gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben gibt auch einen der
branche beauftragten im unternehmen zu
haben und eine beauftragte die dann auch
regelmäßig schulungen tatsächlich
durchführt und wir werden auch für die
positiv subventionierung das heißt in
steuerlast zum beispiel bei unternehmen
dass es in öffentlichen unternehmen
schwer umsetzbar aber zumindest bei den
privatunternehmen wird das auf jeden
fall was was unterstützen können so ohne
eine quote nennt geht er einen schritt
auf die kehrseite zu
ja ok die seite die für die migrations
kultur es kann jetzt auch ein
kompromissvorschlag machen
wir haben uns überlegt dass wir die
quote zwar immer noch wollen aber gerne
einbetten wollen noch in mehrere
sensibilisierungs angebote dass sie
sobald es wieder eine verbesserung der
ungleichheit gibt auch wieder abschaffen
würden das ist ganz wichtig ist bevor
die quote kommt dass klar ist dass wir
eine anerkennung haben darüber dass es
diskriminierung gibt dass wir das
erreichen dass wir auf der basis dieser
anerkennung von ungleichheit dann die
quote einführen also nicht im sinne von
so wie man als die quote ohne
irgendeinen grund sondern dass sie gut
eben begründet ist und und verstanden
wird
würdet ihr ein schritt auf die andere
seite zu gehen dabei dem argument sofort
mit ja nicht ich hatte ich echt wenig
bewegt ihr stimmt weil ich mich mit der
quote einfach wahnsinnig schwer tun das
ist für mich ein aktivist isches
instrument um einen punkt auf die agenda
zu bringen aber das ist kein schlüssel
zur lösung des problems deswegen wäre
das für mich ein fauler kompromiss
ich wünsche mit offenen armen
hierhergekommen weil ich jetzt sei
gespannt war eben auf eure argumente die
ich auch sehr berechtigt fand gleich
fand sie auch spannendes war ein sehr
sehr interessantes thema auch ein
kompliziertes thema muss man sagen aber
ich fand den umgang miteinander und wie
wir uns diesem thema gemeinsam genähert
haben fand ich fokussiert bin ich ja
also meine große sorge ist dass
die bundestagswahlen tatsächlich von
manchen parteien oder gruppierungen dazu
genutzt werden auf dem rücken der
migranten letztendlich wählerstimmen zu
gewinnen
ich würde mir wünschen wenn vor allem
die demokratischen parteien hier ein
deutliches zeichen setzen und sich dem
nicht ergeben
ich hoffe das ist nicht in der wahl zum
thema wird spätestens wenn die wahlen
diskutiert wird ist es meistens ja
populistisch und polarisierend und
wirklich nicht hilfreich für hier
lebende menschen sondern am besten nach
der wahl nachdem war nach dem
integrationsgipfel einfach danach
verbindlichkeiten erarbeiten und wir
wünschen uns dass nach dem gipfel eine
umsetzungs gremium noch da ist dass das
ganze dann umsetzt was wir uns wünschen
ich habe jetzt am ende zumindest viele
nicken der katze gesehen und ihr seid
euch zumindest näher gekommen
vielen dank für die diskussion und für
das teilen oder gedanken das war eine
richtig spannende diskussion die uns
glaube ich allen noch einmal gezeigt hat
wie wichtig es ist dass wir noch mehr
weiter diskutieren uns noch mehr darüber
austauschen wie wir unsere diverse
gesellschaft auch wirklich sichtbar
machen können in allen bereichen jetzt
nach dieser diskussion lasse mir doch
gerne mal ein kommentar da und schreibt
was diese mit euch gemacht hat was denkt
er zu dem thema was wären eure
alternativ und lösungsvorschläge an
falls euch die folge gefallen hat da
lasst doch gerne hier ein voll oder
guckt hier oben ein weiteres video zum
thema und hier unten ein weiteres video
von 13 fragen